Canada's communication security
establishment or CSE is renewing its
warning on the need for quote heightened
vigilance for cyber attacks in the days
to come it comes as Ukrainian president
philodamir zielinski visits Canada his
second time since taking office in 2019.
the CSE says it is not uncommon to see
an increase in cyber attacks against
NATO countries that support Ukraine
including when they host Ukrainian
officials website operators especially
those behind government and critical
infrastructure are being urged to
bolster their protection against cyber
threats multiple Canadian government
websites have been the target of cyber
attacks just this month websites for
Yukon Manitoba Prince Edward Island and
Nunavut were shut down September 14th
with Quebec experiencing an attack the
day before all but UConn said denial of
service tactics were used when attackers
flood a Target site with traffic and
crash it the CSE also said in June the
federal government faced hourly cyber
attacks by hostile foreign actors Sami
Corey with the Canadian Center for cyber
security told the westwester Sadie
Stevenson at the time Russia and Russian
aligned hackers are ramping up efforts
to disrupt critical infrastructure on an
average day we block between five and
six billion signals coming against the
government these are automated systems
that are looking for vulnerabilities
Curry's warning came after an assessment
by the CSE that Russian aligned hackers
May seek to disrupt Canada's oil and
natural gas sector that assessment
warned not only could Canada be a Target
but could be impacted by an attack on
the U.S due to cross-border integration
as the landscape visits Ottawa and
Toronto cyber security officials say
they continue to monitor potential
threats and neutralize them when they
occur
Sean Preble Global News